welcome to my video series of file
techniques explained in five minutes
where I explain a concept of biology in
less than five minutes or so now if you
haven't yet subscribed to my channel
please hit that subscribe button and
don't forget to press the bell icon to
get repeated notification about latest
updates the today's installment we'll be
talking about East to hybrid system
which is an important way to study
protein put the interaction in vitro
mind that you cannot use this technique
to study protein protein interaction in
vivo
now East before is two hybrid we should
understand a basic metabolic principle
inside the East now East can metabolize
galactose and they need enzymes for that
which is encoded by gal gene and the
transcription factor that transcribe
these genes is known as gal for now gal
4 has a activation domain and the DNA
binding domain DNA binding domain binds
to the DNA and activation domain
interacts with the polymerase which
would help the transcription to initiate
now in East to hybrid system you have
two plasmid one plasmid is known as beta
plasmid second-class milk is known as
fish plasmid so you think that a protein
a is interacting with protein B so your
bait would be protein because you want
to understand whether a is interacting
with B or C or B so your bait is protein
a now you genetically encode protein a
in this pits bait plasmid so it's an
expression vector and it would express
give rise to the bait protein which is
itself a chimera of gel for activation
domain and the bait protein
similarly the fish protein would be a
chimera of fish protein and the gal for
DNA binding domain now let's say the
alpha TNA binding domain and the
activator domain what would interact
with each other only if beta and fish
interacts with each other and the
readout
by which we would understand that the
transcription is happening is by putting
a reporter gene by understanding what
the reporter gene is expressing we would
understand whether the bait and the fish
are interacting and in turn whether the
gal so
a B and the gal for DVD is interacting
with each other now the if the bait and
the fish class Mason interacts so
definitely the target gene would be
transcribed in this case it's an
important gene now if they don't
interact the target gene won't be
transcribed right it's a simple readout
and the reporter gene is has to be
fairly simple it could be a metabolic
gene for example the reporter in this
case is his reporter this would give
rise to histidine and we would use the
east train which cannot metabolize still
in itself and we would grow the East in
a histidine depleted media so it would
own the East colony would only grow if
these particular paid and the fish
plasmid interacts and thereby the
history Porter is produced right now the
way we do this is we have a single bit
plasmid let's say the bait plasmid give
rise to the protein a and we want to
understand whether protein a is
interacting with a plethora of proteins
so we would have multiple fish plasmid
in which several cDNA for different
protein be cloned and then the base the
bait plasmid and the fish plasmid would
be Co transfected into the east and the
East would be grown now the way we read
out the data is we spot the East
colonies according to dilution and try
to understand what the colony has formed
if the colony has formed that means the
gal gene is the histidine gene is
transcribed and that in turn means the
protein has interacted with each other
which would give rise to the
transcription so in this particular
situation in so in this particular
situation you can see they are
interacting with each other but other
situations they are not interacting with
each other and as a result the
situations when they are not interacting
with each other you are not seeing any
kind of colonies they are right so that
is how we would understand two proteins
are interacting with each other or not
so if you liked my video give it a quick
thumbs up and don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you
you